hello and welcome to this video playing
to be 2002 and he's got almost 2002 very
close so a double of him kill oh yeah
this is a game that hopefully he gets me
back above 2400 anything below really
feels a bit wrong so what is to be going
to do c6 is what they usually play okay
and this is possible as well however
their arm is this not this is quite
tricky for blackest when I'm trying the
same and so easy to to play like this is
already a very problematic blacks
position he is already quite bad where's
my ideas just 93 rooty one and you have
a hard time to get get out of all those
pins and pins forks what not the black
Queen also has very little space really
Wow
[Music]
okay what is Swiss I mean that that must
be downright lost not 94 yeah yeah first
this and now let's see how you kill this
off G for you
yeah means the yg5 cannot prevent that
yeah you can't win with g3p three stuff
sometimes quickly yeah this is um yeah
reasonably well-known line that's bad
for black here after c5 it's already a
little bit difficult to maintain an
equal position you can I'm not totally
sure what is relatively best yeah but
what I do know is that like from here
it's difficult really difficult after
this black is really on the ropes
already like here you we have a hard
time to to get get developed yeah it's
also this is super strong as you see the
engine is already on 0.7 and I suspect
it will actually climb even even more I
made it in accuracy what is that what is
in accuracy age form yeah okay well it's
plus eight you know yeah so from here
it's already very difficult this is
relatively better but this is a very
thankless task yet to play this position
you know what can if you absolutely have
no better idea take on c6 and play on
that on those pawns but a move like that
is also not easy to play well it's just
a bit quicker the bishop on g2 is strong
yeah but but here I think it's already
very very tough I think relatively best
it's probably really Queen d6 what the
engine is giving however this is a
really tough move to make like it's now
suffering with the weak structure
forever and here is six losses but it's
very difficult to play
I have all those natural moves no it's
it's lost after 94 no just it's just a
way okay guys thanks for watching